foci csapatnál is az ilyen sztár
jáátékosokat hogyha összerakjuk egy
helyre akkor akik akik csak magukkal
vannak elfoglalva az az nem lehet nem
lesz egy hatékony csapat hatékony
csapatban fontos az hogy hogy segítsd és
összejátsz hogy a többiekkel is
lehetőséget hogy tudod az a vicces ebbe
hogy a patkányoknál figyelték meg hogy a
patkányok nagyon szociálisak amú
egyfolytában egymással birkóznak és ha
egy patkány 10 százkal nagyobb a tömege
mint a a másiknak akkor örökké ő nyer
tehát amikor birkóznak akkor elég ti
százal különbség ahhoz hogy mindig a
nagyobb nyerjen viszont van egy olyan
belső ját szabály is a patkányoknál hogy
mindig a gyengébb hívj ki az erősebbet
odamelyik kicsit táncos akkor elkezdenek
egyet birkózni na de az van hogy ha a
nagyobb játékos nem hagyja nyerni a a
kisebb játékost mármint a kisebb
patkányt 30%-ba tehát hogy 10 alkalomból
háromszor nem hagyja nyerni a kisebbet
akkor többet nem fogják elhívni így van
és akkor gyakorlatilag ez a amúgy a
csimpánzoknál is érvényes tehát az
alfaahím nem a legdurvább
legbrutálisabb csimpánz hanem egy olyan
személy aki képes kapcsolatot teremteni
a a gyengékkel a nöstényekkel vagy a
gyermekekkel vagy a kis csimpánzokkal
tehát egy ilyen spontán etika kialakul a
csimpánzoknál is és a patkányoknál is de
kialakult a pubgnél pubg kultúráb is az
embereknél is abszolút tehát